let's figure out what 6.3 divided by
0.25 is and when I look at something
like this the first thing that I think
about is well is there a way that I can
rewrite this so instead of dividing it
by 25 hundredths instead of dividing it
by 0.25 I could divide it by a whole
number maybe 25 and so how do I turn 25
hundredths into 25 well if I multiply it
by if I multiply by 10 once then the
decimal moves one spot to the right and
if I multiply it by 10 twice then I'm
going to move two spots to the right and
25 hundredths is going to become 25 I
multiplied by 10 twice which is the same
thing as multiplying by 100 now of
course I can't only do it to 0.25 that
would change the value of this entire
expression I also have to do it to 6.3
if I move the decimal to the right twice
over here to get a whole number I got to
move the decimal twice to the right over
here so let's see if I move it to the
right once I get 63 so that's one
multiplication by 10 and now I want to
move it to the right again and you might
say wait wait there doesn't look like
there's any other digit here that I can
move to the right of and we just have to
remind ourselves it's six point three
well that's going to be the same thing
as six point three zero or we could
actually add as many zeros as we want to
the end of this and not change the value
it's still six point three six and three
tenths is the same thing as six and 30
hundredths so now I can move the decimal
one more spot to the right and so I'm
multiplying by ten again and it becomes
630 so six point three divided by 0.25
is the same thing as 630 divided by 25
let me do that again because this is
really the tricky part or the artful
part when you're dividing decimals if I
were to write 0.25 being divided into
being divided into six point three six
let me do it six six point three now
what I care about is moving this decimal
to the right far enough so that this
becomes a whole number I don't have to
move it any further just far
enough so this becomes a whole number
and then I have to move this the same
number of times to the right but the
goal is to make this a whole number not
to make the 6.3 a whole number although
that is going to happen for this
particular case so if I move it two
spaces to the right so one to 0.25
becomes 25 and then 6.3 becomes would
one space two spaces to the right it
becomes 630 and so let me let me clarify
that let me just clear all of this stuff
our way out of the way to just make that
clear what I just did so we don't have
to deal with all this messiness when
we're actually doing our long division
now and so this one over here let me
erase all of this business and we are
ready to do some we're ready to do some
some long division all right so now this
is just straight forward dividing a
two-digit number into a three-digit
number and so we could say well 25 goes
into 6 zero times so let's keep going 25
goes into 63 let's see 2 times 25 is 50
3 times 25 is 75 so that's too much so
we want to go 2 times 2 times 25 is
going to be 50 and we can subtract or if
you didn't know 2 times 25 is going to
be 50 you could have said 2 times 5 is
10 carry the 1 or regroup the 1 2 times
2 is 4 plus 1 is 5 so we got 50 and now
we subtract and we get 3 minus 0 is 3 6
minus 5 is 1 and now we bring down the
next digit we can bring down this is 0
and we could say 25 and let me scratch
this out so I don't confuse myself later
25 goes into 130 how many times let's
see 25 times 4 is 120 5 times 5 is 125
25 times 6 would be a hundred 50 so
that's too big so I'm going to go 5
times so 5 times and I write it's very
important to keep track of my places
right here I brought down the 0 to make
the 13 into 130 so when I say 25 goes
into 135 times I write it above the
oh I write it right above the zero right
over there and then five times
twenty-five five times five we already
know what it is but I'll just figure it
out five times five is 25 regroup the to
five times two is ten plus two is twelve
and now we can now we can subtract and
you might know offhand well is 130 minus
20 125 is going to be five or if you
like you could do a little regrouping
you can make this you could take a ten
from there and then put the 10 in the
ones place and this becomes 10 10 minus
5 is 5 now we aren't done yet we want to
divide this completely so we can bring
down another zero we can bring down
another zero and I'm picking an
appropriate color too for the next so
I'll use well I use the green once it
will use yellow so once again I can
bring down another zero but I have to be
very careful you I can't just I can't
just throw a zero right over there
that's going to turn 630 into 6300 I
have to be very particular say now to
look look this next is zero I'm going to
put that's going to be after the decimal
now 630 is the same thing as 630 point
zero and if I'm going to add a decimal
there I want to throw the decimal right
above it you need to be very careful
with that but now we're ready to start
bringing down the zero so let's bring
down this 0 and we have a 50 how many
times does 25 go into 50 let me scratch
this out so you don't confuse ourselves
later 25 goes 2 times into 52 times 25
is in fact 50 is in fact 50 and so now
we can subtract and we now have a
remainder of zero and there's nothing
left to bring down other than zeros and
we have a remainder of zero so we are
done
dividing completely you take 630 divided
by 25 it's 25 point 2 or if you look at
our original problem if you look at our
original problem which was 6 point 3
divided by 0.25 that also is 25 point 2
2 so this is also going to be 25 point
to let me rewrite it let me rewrite it
so our original problem was 6 point 3
divided by 0.25 which we just figured
out we just figured out is 25
and two-tenths and we're done